IN THE SPRING, SOMETHING THE
KREMLIN INSIST THEY WANT TO
PURSUE.
BRET.
>> Bret: JILLIAN, THANK YOU.
TONIGHT, SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
ARE WEIGHING ARGUMENTS ABOUT
GERRYMANDERING.
THE PRACTICE OF SHAPING
POLITICAL VOTING DISTRICTS FOR
PARTISAN GAIN.
THE SPECIFIC CASE INVOLVES A
RURAL AREA IN MARYLAND,
TRADITIONALLY BLUE STATE WHERE
REPUBLICANS ARE POSITIONED TO
GAIN.
CORRESPONDENT DOUG McKELWAY
TELLS US THAT HAS IMPLICATIONS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
>> ROSCOE BARTLETT IS UNUSUAL.
HE'S A REPUBLICAN IN MARYLAND
WHO WON REELECTION IN THE SIXTH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT FOR 20
YEARS.
GOVERNOR MARTIN O'MALLEY, A
DEMOCRAT, AND THE STATE'S
DEMOCRATIC GENERALS AND LEE
DECIDED HE MUST GO.
THEY RESHAPED HIS DISTRICT.
"IT WAS MY INTENT TO CREATE A
DISTRICT WHERE THE PEOPLE WOULD
BE MORE LIKELY TO ELECT A
DEMOCRAT THAN A REPUBLICAN."
O'MALLEY OPENLY ADMITTED IN A
RECENT DEPOSITION.
IT WORKS.
>> IN 2010, ROSCOE BARTLETT WON
BY 20 POINTS.
IN 2012, AFTER THE GERRYMANDER,
HE LOST BY 21 POINTS.
IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY COUNTER
DEMOCRATIC.
>> THE HIGH COURT HEARD
ARGUMENTS TODAY IN MARILYN'S
CASE.
PLAINTIFFS HAVE A NOVEL ARGUMENT
THAT THE GERRYMANDER VIOLATED
THE 14TH AMENDMENT PROTECTION
RIGHTS AND FIRST AMENDMENT EQUAL
SPEECH RIGHTS, PUNISHING VOTERS
FOR SUPPORTING THE REPUBLICAN.
>> IF EVER THERE WERE A
VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, IT IS THIS.
>> THE JUSTICE APPEARED TO BE
SWAYED THAT DEMOCRATS WERE
OVERLY INFLUENCED BY POLITICS
CARVING OUT THE SIXTH DISTRICT.
JUSTICE ELENA KAGAN NOTING HOW
MUCH MORE EVIDENCE OF PARTISAN
ATTEMPT COULD WE NEED.
CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS AT
ACCREDITED OBJECTION TO THE
WEIGHT WAS WITHDRAWN IS THAT
INSTANT TAP INTERNAL LOGIC.
THEY STRUGGLED BEHIND WHEN
JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR CALLED
DEFINING GERRYMANDERING.
>> IS THIS AN ISSUE WE CAN
DECIDE AND RESOLVE OR IS IT
SOMETHING BEST LEFT OF THE
POLITICAL BRANCHES?
>> THE COURT MAY BE HESITANT TO
ACT.
IN ROUGHLY TWO-THIRDS OF THE
STATES, .
THIS IS THE SECOND GERRYMANDER
CASE THE COURT HAS HEARD THIS
TERM.
THE FIRST INVOLVED A REPUBLICAN
REDRAWING OF DISTRICTS IN
WISCONSIN.
BY HEARING APPEALS FROM BOTH
PARTIES, JUSTICE KENNEDY MAY BE
LOOMING LARGE AGAIN AS A